let's do a math problem what is 30
divided by 2 and 1/2 in school we would
do this problem by long division we
would set up 30 as the dividend the
number 2 and 1/2 which is our divisor
becomes 2 point 5 now to perform the
long division we need to move the
decimal point over so 2 and 1/2 becomes
25 since we move the decimal point to
the right we're going to have to adjust
it on 30 so we move the decimal point
over to the left or do we move the
decimal point over to the right and when
we move it over to the right we have an
empty spot so do we add a 0 all right
this is getting confusing but don't
worry about it this is pressure Locker
in this video I'm going to teach you an
easy way to divide numbers that's known
as the ancient Egyptian method let's
return to our problem and forget
everything that you've learned in school
I'm going to teach you how the ancient
Egyptians did this around 1650 BC which
was over 3,600 years ago this problem is
documented on a papyrus and the method
they use as they count it up multiples
of the divisor two and a half so they
started out by saying one part is two
and a half and we're going to count up
parts until we get to 30 so two parts of
two and a half we double two and a half
to get five and then we can also take
ten parts of two and a half to get 25
and now we've pretty much solved the
problem we can add up five and 25 to get
30 so we're adding up to 30 which is
because we're doing 30 divided by two
and a half and now to get our answer our
quotient we just add up the parts so we
add up two parts and ten parts and we
get 12 and that's our answer 30 divided
by two-and-a-half is 12
so it's a pretty cool method and you can
use it anytime instead of long division
so let's try another problem let's do
one hundred divided by seven we're going
to count up multiples of seven until we
get to a hundred so we start out that
one part is equal to seven we can
clearly jump to ten parts which will be
seventy
we're still short by about thirty so we
can add four parts of seven which is 28
we're short by two parts or two until we
get 200 so 2/7 parts will be equal to
two so now we've added up multiples
until we get to 100 so we have 70 plus
28 plus two and that gets us to our
hundred to get our quotient we add up
the number of parts we have ten parts
for parts and two seventh parts which
gets us to our answer of 14 and 2/7 and
there you go this is an easy way to
divide numbers and you don't have to use
a long division if you were to ask
people about this in school or try and
look this up on the internet it's also
known as the partial quotient method
this is a valid way to divide numbers
you may hear that this is new math or
part of the Common Core Curriculum but
whenever people tell you that it's new
math just tell them this is actually
very ancient it was developed 3,600
years ago by Egyptians and they actually
used it if you liked this video please
check out another video I made about how
Egyptians multiplied numbers using only
the process of doubling and adding I
hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math you can get my books they're great
books about math there are links in the
video description you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions which you can
follow on Facebook and Google+ you can
follow me at fresh towel Walker on
Twitter Instagram Tumblr and Pinterest
and you can support me on patreon